to the first heat wave of the year now
the risk of heat exhaustion or even
stroke
remains high and can happen to anybody
kate houston tells us who is most at
risk
and how the pandemic could actually have
lowered your heat tolerance
we really feel the effects we've been
drinking a lot more water i would say
the splash pad at centennial hills park
was the perfect spot for families to
cool off david hawkinson came prepared
my daughter is in like the sunscreen
long sleeve shirt
and loose fitting clothing water water
water
parents like eileen eadie say it's
better to be proactive because heat
illnesses can happen at any time
the heat exhaustion sneaks up on you you
know you think you're
you think you're just a little warm or
you think oh i'm nauseous but you know
it must be something
i ate and and those things are all the
warning signs as temperatures heat up
it's important to remember basic levels
of protection such as wearing a hat
putting on sunscreen and drinking lots
of water
we're most definitely planning on a long
summer paramedic samuel sheller says
young kids and the elderly are
especially prone to heat exhaustion
and stroke some exhaustion symptoms
include heavy sweating dizziness and
nausea
heat stroke symptoms can include hot
skin with no sweating
rapid pulse and confusion the heat does
not discriminate against anybody so
if you're out there in the heat for long
amounts times you will feel the effects
due to the pandemic forcing people to
stay inside sheller says it's important
for everyone to recondition themselves
to the high temperatures
taking your time out in the heat going
easy you know maybe the first couple
weeks of the summer
heat wave don't spend too much time
outside and really just kind of ease
into it this summer
kate houston 8 news now